it's very difficult to talk about or
think about happiness when one is
experienced tragedy and in fact when
people actually break down when they
give themselves the permission to be
human whether it's by crying or sharing
their emotions with others when they
break down there actually much more
likely to get over their tragedy whereas
people who say okay I'm going to pull
through this I'm going to be strong I'm
not going to let these emotions take
over me they're actually people who
would struggle for much longer periods
of time after the tragedy has occurred
we need to give our mind our body our
emotions at time to heal and it that's
when the the natural healer kicks in
when we let it take its course rather
than suppress it
many people talk about PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorder which is
quite common whether after 911 or people
coming back from Afghanistan or Iraq and
however very few people talk about
post-traumatic growth which potentially
is is more common than and then PTSD
post-traumatic growth comes about when
we give ourselves the permission to be
human when we allow ourselves to
experience the emotions it comes when we
interpret or reinterpret the event and
and look for actively look for a meaning
in what had just happened to us and it
comes when we share our experiences when
we open up rather than closed down so it
is possible to experience post-traumatic
growth it's possible for many more
people who have gone through trauma who
have gone through difficult experiences
and to experience growth as as a result
and this is the power of positive
psychology of research because what
psychologists know today is what we can
do when we can actively do to to
experience more growth following
hardship
there is actually very interesting
research about luck by Richard Wiseman
who's a British psychologist and what he
shows is that there are actually certain
characteristics that can be learned and
can be taught associated with with lucky
people so it's things like being more
open to opportunities and little things
like trying new things whether it's a
walking back home using a different
route every day or varying ones ones
menu and it's also people who believe in
luck who end up having more luck so he
created a luck school teaching people
how to become luckier and it works
the ultimate currency is happiness it's
the end toward which all others and the
ultimate currency is happiness it's the
end in the words of Aristotle toward
which all other goals lead and why do we
want to be successful because we believe
that it will make us happier why do we
want more money because we believe that
it would make us happier and if working
hard at a certain profession certain
area and does not make us happier but it
will make us more successful than then
why bother I mean ideally what we want
to find is something that is personally
meaningful to us something that we
experience as pleasurable and then
pursue it and then we can have the best
of both worlds we can be as successful
as well as happy but the key to that is
to also enjoy the the process the
journey toward this that success because
success in and of itself and cannot will
not make us